j'ai regardé toutes les séries matilda
ahmed je sens que tu commences à l'actif
élus quoi tout à l'heure j'ai beaucoup
ça tu comment celles qui ont ils
marchent dans la rue et ou encore dans
la rue aujourd'hui exactement grosse
séquence dans la rue d'ailleurs on
commence avec les séries benjamin chirac
pour ce week-end j'étais sur idf1 je
suis revenu avec des images des mystères
de l'amour
alors ce week-end les acteurs que
l'amérique bas bien sûr ce week-end des
acteurs donné rendez-vous en discothèque
alors on savait qu'ils jouaient pas
super bien maintenant en plus on sait
qu'ils dansent pas super bien non
regardez bien le théâtre danse de
ringard à côté vincent moscato dans
danse avec les stars c'est michael
jackson est bon
tél
animaux t
ap ap ap
[Applaudissements]
comme ça il s'est concentré avant de
lancer dans la nuit les commandes à
personne et que je retourne lorient 6-3
beau générer la censure vous d'ailleurs
c'est vrai ça se passe bien l'accueil
d'âge deux eaux denses plus à l'est
après ça je suis passé sur le banc
daniela bendelac c'est pas c'est pas à
l'accueil ans et une série une
telenovelas mexicaine alors j'ai grillé
le mec te griller le maître le plus
courtois et le plus sympa du monde quand
il surprend sa meuf en train de tromper
normal
[Musique]
dakar est moralement inappropriée karina
freddy ce n'est pas du tout ce qu'il
paraît ta conduite peu par et moralement
il approprié mais leurs appels n'avaient
leur amener un petit verre il est à deux
doigts à et cette chronique nations ont
la dédicace à l'accueil d'âge de passer
sur eva luna une autre télé novelas
alors là j'ai surpris en docteur donné
rendez-vous à sa passion mais quand on
voit la tournure que prend le rendez
vous on sent très vite que le délire du
docteur quand il était enfant s'était
appelé les gens de redire à l'eau n'ont
rien mais dragage et le même délire en
images merci d'être venus renata assieds
toi s'il te plait je vous demande d'être
d'être bref si c'est possible
en vérité je n'ai pas grand chose à vous
dire
[Applaudissements]
bon alors j'ai voulu vous ramener des
images de ma série préférée le bureau
des légendes sauf qu'on a viré le bureau
et les légendes de la reine blanche
alors rappelez vous il ya quelques temps
je vous ramenez les images d'un acteur
qui a eu une envie pressante en plein
d'audace et cambrai et qui avait
complètement zappé qu'il était filmé et
nous attendons le verdict
[Musique]
majesté excusez moi je vais pisser
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un vrai beau succès dans ce
scénario c'est tenir six mois c'était
lors il avait justement je me suis rendu
compte que c'était courant dans cette
série d'avoir des envies pressantes en
fait quand ils savent pas passer d'une
séquence à l'autre nous ont une envie
pressante c'est comme dire qu elle va me
le paie très cher quand je le mettrais
la main dessus
au prix très fort
[Applaudissements]
en fait ma vessie aux bleus pour
décharger un coup c'est parce qu'ils
boivent sur le tournage mais j'entends
l'étoile c'est plus en tout les jours je
mettrai pas bon après ça chez lui dans
la rue a bien sûr elbit et le bdr a
voulu savoir si les français assumer
leurs propos pour ça je suis descendu
dans la rue avec des photos de vous les
chroniqueurs elle aurait demandé un
petit peu ce qu'ils pensent être vous
plaisez laissé vidé leur sac et s'est
passé un truc à un moment donné je peux
pas vous dire quoi qui fait qu'ils ont
un tout petit peu changé
qu'est ce que vous pensez de cette
personne est très joli mois le bel
edward silvert dette c'est vrai je
l'aimé trop a jugé m ah non il fait trop
le mec le problème quand tu dis ça en
fait sa façon parler oui alors maxime
gagné on n'aime pas trop votre monture
met en cause par les ajustements
juridiques et je vous aimais beaucoup
ouais c'est vrai par contre qu'est ce
que ces désaccords
non mais c'était un peu méchante et j'ai
dit non ça se fait pas alors maxime
gagné on n'aime pas trop aucune machine
qu'est ce que tu penses de lui pas ouf
ça va j'aime pas trop non pourquoi
il sert pas à grand chose qu'est ce que
tu penses un petit peu de ses news ces
infos sont moyennes combat poule quand
tu vois que tu étais pas du tout ce que
vous vouliez des très bonnes nouvelles
économiques a fait dix ans et est ce que
vous connaissez cette personne mais bien
sûr alors c'est celui qu'on en entend
moins parler bat toujours très drôle on
aimerait qu'ils soient lâche un peu plus
j'étais en compte par les toits
justement viendra pas ben moi je sais
pas je ne connaissais pas elle est ce
que vous connaissez cette personne mais
bien sûr je connais comment il s'appelle
mathieu
ouais ça regarde l'émission tous les
soirs c'est plus beau des missions
telles voitures préférées
tu la façon dont ça y est c'est moi vous
savez la der des voitures bateaux vous à
mr les soirs et je pense qu'il n'est pas
si bête que ça
[Applaudissements]
du coup j'ai pas fini
vous me croirez ou pas flash news je
crois que maxime gagné a profité de ce
micro trottoir pour se rapprocher d'une
passante
regardez la pécho regarde est-ce que tu
connais j'adore beau gosse ça pourrait
être considéré cui à son numéro du ve
son numéro i et bah ça tombe bien juste
là sa machine
[Musique]
j'avale est rentré dire je te trouvais
super beau gosse des roulettes au numéro
du groupe toujours aussi bien il est un
peu la peau sèche
ce coût serait une petite crème voilà il
ya une connexion année une connexion on
peut y aller on vous laisse
j'ai eu un éclair de gagner ça alors au
bout de combien de temps maxime gagné
ils nous appellent ce qu'on appelle dans
le milieu une maxime ghani selon vous
combien de temps ça a pris avant de tout
gâcher
peut-être c'était peut être un peu plus
rapide
alors vous savez alors un dieu qui l'a
achetée déjà depuis très longtemps je
t'ai vu l'enclos ça se pose pas les
questions sur mon avenir tuer tuer
n'importe quoi c'est important tu me
donnes que je comprends pas en chanson
déjà il ya déjà une question
[Applaudissements]